thank you for joining us i'm john
langler we start with another big delay
for what promises to be one of las vegas
biggest
shows today garth brooks rescheduled his
allegiance stadium show for a second
time it's the latest delay for major
concerts here in las vegas
hector mejia has that story there's no
shortage of excitement among tourists
here at the welcome to las vegas sign as
we get word
of entertainment slowly but surely
coming back there's a new date for
country music singer garth brooks
concert at allegion stadium
we're talking about the concert that was
supposed to be the first one ever at
allegiant in august of last year
it's now scheduled for saturday july
10th instead of february 27th
allegion stadium says brooks had sold
over 65 000 tickets in a matter of 75
minutes
we're hearing dates for other concerts
as well justin bieber tickets are on
sale
for june 4th at t-mobile arena that's
also a concert that was rescheduled from
last year
live entertainment has always been one
of the big draws for vegas and for this
trip
so the fact that it's coming back even
if it's slow is a really good sign
i'm a big edc fan you know we want edc
to come back
to vegas i know everyone can't wait to
party you know living life
here's another one legendary rock and
roll band chicago
is also selling tickets at the venetian
for dates in september
on the 15th 17th and 18th we'll keep you
up to speed and let you know as soon as
we hear more dates
as they pop up on the entertainment
calendar reporting from the welcome to
las vegas sign hector mejia
8 news now